[російською] Звісно, оскільки я хворий авіацією,
то мені би хотілось, щоб багато людей любили авіацію.
[російською] Бо коли торкаються,
коли злітають кудись,
[російською] це як наркотик,
люди кажуть, що хочуть ще.
[російською] І ось це відчуття радості польоту,
емоції, практично мене заряджає.
[російською] Тоді я розумію
для чого працюю та розвиваюсь.
[російською] Десь у збиток своєму бізнесу,
[російською] а десь — у збиток своєму бізнесу.
[російською] У нас, на Західній Україні,
у такому форматі цей аеродром єдиний.
[російською] Найближчий — Цунів,
а це Львів, все ж таки 200 кілометрів.
[російською] Більше таких офіційних ЗПМ [злітно-посадкових
майданчиків] у нашому регіоні немає, аж до Вінниці.
[російською] Ми представляємо
Коломию на всіх авіаційних фестивалях України.
[російською] Окрім того,
я намагаюся літати і за кордон.
[російською] На сьогодні шість літаючих
і три поки не літаючих.
[російською] Плюс три мотодельтаплани,
мотопараплан і, само собою, параплани.
[російською] Також ми підтягнули сюди парашутні стрибки.
[російською] Я два роки тому
отримав інструкторський рейтинг.
[російською] І станом на сьогодні у мене вже
навчено 18 пілотів, які літають самостійно.
[російською] Найінтенсивніше, щоб отримати пілотське,
це потрібно місяць добре працювати.
[російською] Фактично можна, як то кажуть,
і за тиждень — потрібно налітати 48 годин.
[російською] Але це настільки інтенсивна праця,
що методично це неправильно і неграмотно.
[російською] Бо людина повинна злітати, переосмислити,
перетравити це, а потім знову повернутися.
[російською] До мене зараз приїжджають навчатися
і з Києва, і зі Львова, і з Тернополя.
[російською] Я пишаюся, що у Коломиї
вже є прямі вихідці нашої школи.
[російською] Бо західноукраїнська школа знаходиться у Львові,
[російською] але ми, як філіал, навчаємо і в Коломиї.
[російською] Це говорить про те, що наша популярність
зростає і тягнуться люди, які хочуть.
[російською] Від гвинта!
[російською] Зараз ми прогріваємо
двигун до 50 градусів температури мастила,
[російською] і температура охолоджуючої рідини
підходить значно швидше, ніж ми думаємо.
[російською] На жаль, сьогодні погана видимість.
[російською] Точніше, видимість є,
але через серпанок вона нечітка.
[російською] І ось, до речі,
чому називають «блакитні Карпати»,
[російською] бо ось ця зелень,
[російською] на фоні серпанку,
дає таку сизість, блакитного відтінку.
[російською] Перший контрольний виліт
був для мене дуже пам'ятним.
[російською] Я літав на «Л-39».
[російською] І від хвилювання,
що я досягнув того, чого хотів,
[російською] у мене пішла носом кров.
[російською] І ось, вона йде, а я її не можу зупинити.
[російською] І незручно,
бо якщо інструктор побачить — можуть списати.
[російською] Я у кисневій масці,
[російською] і просто витерти не можна,
бо інструктор позаду побачить який стан.
[російською] І я ось так кров
язиком злизував, злизував.
[російською] Потім змусив себе її
зупинити і зупинив.
[російською] Перед виходом з літака іще щось витер.
[російською] Отримав зауваження,
і все, після цього ось так і почав літати.
[російською] Тому перший політ для мене був дуже незабутнім.
[російською] Спочатку історія,
думка та ідея цього аеродрому трапилась
[російською] після того,
як я звільнився з військової служби.
[російською] Тобто пішов на пенсію у 2002 році,
[російською] і зрозумів після цього,
що не зможу жити без авіації.
[російською] Перші кроки, які у мене були, це параплан.
[російською] Освоїв, мені захотілось іще чогось такого,
[російською] перейшов на мотопараплан.
[російською] Потім і цього стало мало.
[російською] Плюс історія, яка трапилась в Індії.
[російською] Це був вже другий рік поїздки в Індію.
[російською] Це точка Бір.
[російською] Ми прилетіли.
[російською] І почали літати тренувальні польоти.
[російською] На третій льотний день
[російською] я домовився виконати
політ зі своїм товаришем з Києва.
[російською] І ми пішли разом на високі гори,
на чотирьохтисячники.
[російською] Так сталось, що десь за 20 хвилин
польоту він пішов на більш низькі висоти.
[російською] Я пішов по цих верхівках
і швидко пройшов близько 40 кілометрів.
[російською] І на зворотньому по часу шляху
я потрапив у потужний спадний потік.
[російською] Крило склалося настільки,
що я не міг його відкрити.
[російською] Залишками крила, яке падало,
я зачепився за виступ скелі.
[російською] При такому різкому гальмуванні
я отримав компресійний перелом хребта.
[російською] Коли зачепився — я одразу дістав радіостанцію
та спробував зв'язатися зі своїм товаришем.
[російською] Я сказав, що мені потрібна допомога,
бо візуально я бачу, що мені визволитися звідси неможливо.
[російською] Вже темніло.
[російською] Дуже сильно темніло
і я зрозумів, що потрібно десь ховатися.
[російською] Десь так ліг.
[російською] Цим самим зігрівався: крило не пропускає
повітря, я дихав та зігрівав повітря навколо себе.
[російською] Наступного дня я прокинувся та зрозумів,
що потрібно якось виходити з цієї ситуації.
[російською] І почав шукати виходи.
[російською] Практично всюди, куди я
намагався пройти, були суцільні скелі.
[російською] Тому вирішив залишатись.
[російською] І тут якраз пошуково-рятувальна
група пішла по мене.
[російською] Я чув їх через радіозв'язок.
[російською] Вони попросили, щоб я розпалив вогонь,
але, фактично, вогонь не було з чого розпалити.
[російською] Я знайшов якісь корінці.
Вони мене, звісно ж, не побачили здалеку.
[російською] Вони не дійшли до мене кілометрів зо п'ять.
[російською] До цього часу в мене сіла радіостанція.
[російською] І згодом, на п'яту добу,
[російською] до вечора була погана погода,
[російською] я почув шум гелікоптера.
[російською] Я розкрив крило,
для того, щоб його було видно.
[російською] Справа у тому, що я був трохи за бугром.
[російською] І він, крайній віраж,
бачу, не доходить до мене.
[російською] Я тоді беру крило, тягну і
біжу на те місце, де він міг би мене побачити.
[російською] Але крило зачепилося за якийсь камінь,
я падаю, і гелікоптер полетів.
[російською] І тут я отримав таке розчарування:
я розумів, що якщо людина літала і не знайшла,
[російською] то вона може туди вже і не повернутись.
[російською] І ось, наступного ранку вийшло сонце,
[російською] це був дуже теплий ранок.
[російською] У цей момент я знову почув гелікоптер.
[російською] Я до цього часу знайшов місце,
з якого краще видно де я є.
[російською] Я його вже ретельно та акуратно розклав.
[російською] І десь на третій віраж
я зрозумів, що він мене бачить.
[російською] Бо він почав точно на мене знижуватись.
[російською] І ми далі полетіли ще нижче, в Палампур.
[російською] Після цього всього дружина мені сказала:
«Все, параплан закриваємо,
[російською] давай займатися серйознішою авіацією».
[російською] Літак «Zodiac 601»,
той, який американської розробки.
[російською] Це літак, КІТ-набір до якого
постачається з запчастин, таких, як частини літака,
[російською] і такий КІТ-набір коштує 16 тисяч доларів.
[російською] Він надсилається у будь-яку точку світу,
[російською] а кожен господар
на місці його збирає, ставить двигун,
[російською] і літак готовий до експлуатації.
[російською] Правда, щоб його зібрати,
необхідно вечорами більше року працювати.
[російською] Як правило, це літак особистого користування.
[російською] Тобто при виробництві зрозуміло,
що люди будуть працювати, а тільки вечорами збирати.
[російською] Першою покупкою в мене був «Zodiac 601»,
[російською] на якому я почав виконувати польоти.
[російською] І розумів, що необхідний якийсь аеродром.
[російською] Я шукав довго місце.
[російською] Сам аеродром у 2010 році,
договір оренди підписали у 2011 році,
[російською] Зрозуміло, що інші літаки
почали до мене підтягуватись,
[російською] і я прийняв рішення, що потрібен ангар.
[російською] Після того, як у ході розвитку ангар заповнився,
ми вирішили, що потрібен другий ангар.
[російською] Коли вже заповнився другий ангар,
[російською] прийняли рішення, що потрібен третій ангар.
[російською] Я популяризую Коломию,
можна сказати, що з его, але его хороше.
[російською] Туристична частина авіаторів присутня.
[російською] Ми влаштовуємо екскурсії тут, містом.
[російською] Я проводжу тут різні фестивалі,
зокрема у нас закріпився фестиваль «Івана Купала».
[російською] Ми, в принципі, щороку це робимо.
[російською] Але вони в захваті
і прилітають знову подивитися.
[російською] Це дає тенденцію до розвитку готелів
та закладів громадського харчування.
[російською] Коли бачать Коломию,
думають: «Історичне місто»,
[російською] а коли дізнаються,
що ще аеродром є — це багатьох шокує.
[російською] Полетів, вирішив проблеми
і повернувся назад.
[російською] Де ви це зробите на машині?
Машиною тільки півдня туди, півдня назад.
[російською] А коли їздити і вирішувати питання?
[російською] А так він за чотири години
вирішив свої питання, ось у чому переваги.
[російською] Я хочу, щоб Коломия розвивалась,
хочу, щоб вона росла.
[російською] Бо я бачу відтік молоді
[російською] в область, з області — у столицю.
[російською] Я хочу створити умови,
щоб молодь, бізнесмени, не їхали звідси,
[російською] а розуміли, що можна розвиватись
у Коломиї, піднімати Коломию.
[російською] А якщо є якісь
бізнес-справи за межами Коломиї,
[російською] то можна мати свій літак:
сів і полетів.
[російською] У Київ — одна година 45 хвилин,
у Харків — три години, в Одесу — дві з половиною години.
[російською] Коли діти приходять,
я завжди кажу, що це стимул заробляти більше.
[російською] Здобувайте освіту.
[російською] Виховуйте себе,
засвоюйте все, що вам дають,
[російською] будьте старанними,
і тоді у вас бізнес піде.
[російською] Будете добре заробляти.
[російською] Тоді зможете чогось досягнути.
[російською] Тобто це як стимул, це як крок,
[російською] те, чого людина повинна прагнути.